how psyched you cuz I think you a lot
when these these stories break then all
this UFO stuff which you've been you
know you've been pretty involved in and
you got the big interviews with those uh
with those pilots you talked to those
guys with the San Diego incident is that
where it was in commander Faber
yeah I actually talked to Jeremy Korbel
and George Knapp yesterday and it goes
up today it's probably out right now and
that's a pretty heavy podcast George
Knapp is a journalist who broke the Bob
Lazar story in 1989 he's a legit
investigative journalist for Las Vegas
he you know he catches the mob and bad
guys and scam artists and stuff like
he's a legit journalist and has been his
whole career and was real hesitant to
take on that story because it seems so
bonkers
in 1989 Bob Lazar saying he's working on
back-engineering UFOs and they work on
this element that's only theoretical and
this element allows them to bend gravity
and [ __ ] shoot from point to point
almost instantaneously everybody's like
you're crazy but then as time has gone
on and these videos have come out that
have shown these crafts and shown them
with that tic tac craft that was off of
San Diego that was blocking their
tracking devices and then went from it
went from 60,000 feet to 0 0 feet above
sea level in less than a second they
have no idea what the [ __ ] it is they
have no idea what it's doing and the
guys down there in San Diego who are in
the military were saying we're seeing
them all the time we see them every
couple weeks they don't know where they
are
they think they're docking with
something under the water sometimes
these are rock-solid soldiers I mean
these are Air Force pilots these are
like the cream of the crop right
American military they're not [ __ ]
artists like if you meet commander
flavor that guy is there's nothing about
that guy at all that's a [ __ ] artist
that guy is a rock-solid military man
and when he tells you he's flying a
fighter pilot and there's something that
does things in the sky that he can't
explain and no one knows how they do it
no one understands that there's no
visible method of propulsion
and this thing goes from 60,000 feet
down to one in a second and that's just
how fast the radar registers it they
don't even really know how fast it was
moving it might have been instant no BS
you can make it this is what do they
have any other video that stuff that's
not released there's got to be something
to make they track that they'd if they
have that video they have to have other
stuff that me that the military isn't
releasing good question the fact that
they're releasing any of these videos is
kind of crazy because they're really
they're releasing these things and you
you can hear the pilots they're
voiceovers going holy [ __ ] what is that
what the [ __ ] is that like these guys
are freaking out you could hear in their
voices they're not actors there's
fighter pilots experienced military
pilots that are seeing things move in a
way that defies all of our understanding
of propulsion systems what the [ __ ] is
that you can't write those guys off
those guys can't be written off or
dismissed because they end up they
understand propulsion they understand
lift and when they have no idea what
they're looking at those guys I find
very convincing I don't believe a lot of
UFO stuff but those guys I can't not
believe I would bet the house on
commander flavor I bet the house on that
guy the guy who's on my podcast
I bet the house that he what he is
saying is a hundred percent true what he
is saying he saw he's not making any of
it up do you think they know yeah I know
Snowden you asked and it was so
interesting that he hadn't found any
evidence which could just mean that that
any evidence they have is kind of like
on a circular a system that isn't
accessible from the outside but do you
think there are things that they know
that they're not saying or do you think
that we pretty much know what they know
at this point that's a good question man
I wish I knew I wish it made sense it
doesn't make sense it seems like I bet
the government knows almost as little as
we do that's what I bet I bet there's
some I bet it's very compartmentalized
and I bet in some very high-level
meetings this is discussed and I bet if
you're below a certain pay grade you
never hear it and I bet there there's a
need-to-know basis in terms of what they
found out what's possible what's
[ __ ] what's what what are they
putting out just just to send smoke
signal so Russia thinks we have me I'm
sure there's games and you know
propaganda the things get manipulated in
terms of military might and but I think
there's clearly some indication that
something's going on that they don't
understand and if this thing is from
another planet
it's probably better than if this thing
is from Russia or China like if Russia
or China can do something that we can't
explain like that we're [ __ ] yeah this
is what George Knapp said on the podcast
yesterday he's like the worry is that
this technology is something that we can
crack and whoever cracks it first is
gonna have incredible superiority over
the rest of the world I mean obviously
we all have nuclear bombs we do blow
each other up period but one of the
things that was they were talking about
George Knapp was that these things have
shown up around military facilities and
lit up launch codes on on
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
then shut them down disappeared like
they've they've started launch codes
where these people are freaking out
these people in the base like holy [ __ ]
we're gonna start World War three and
then they take off like this has
happened apparently in more than one
occasion and they think it's happening
in Russia too I think they occasionally
just show up and they want to see like
what we do like what are we doing and
the thing is there's a big uptick of
these right after Hiroshima and Nagasaki
so throughout human history there's been
UFO sightings but a lot of the UFO
sightings came after the the late 40s
after the bombs were dropped and after
all those experiments in the desert
Nevada I mean they they they blew up a
lot of [ __ ] nuclear bombs I don't know
if you've ever seen those those tests
videos we could see the map of the
country it shows you the year and every
year there's more and more nuclear bombs
go off whoo there's a lot they blew up a
lot and that's when the UFO sighting
started really amplifying which means
that they may see I always thought like
well maybe we're thinking we see things
because our technology gets better so it
does science influence what we're
seeing or are we really influencing what
we think worse but then it's like that
makes sense maybe there was something to
do with it if they're legitimately UFOs
maybe did something to do with the fact
that there was nuclear testing that they
either either put us more on their radar
or they want to know exactly what it is
yeah who the [ __ ] knows man but it's fun
it's a fun subject it's a fun